hoy en Paraguay acaba la campaña
electoral los principales candidatos
Santiago peña del partido Colorado hoy
en alegres de la concertación están
prácticamente empatados Eso sí a pesar
de los petardos que estamos oyendo ha
sido una campaña diferente porque el
partido Colorado que actualmente
gobierna Paraguay ha tenido problemas de
financiación consiguiendo al final tres
millones de dólares menos de lo esperado
y esto por las económicas impuestas por
el gobierno de los Estados Unidos
Horacio cartes presidente del partido
Colorado y declarado por la embajada de
los Estados Unidos significa
significativamente corrupto Por esa
razón cartes no ha podido hacer campaña
junto a su delfín Santiago Peña tampoco
el actual presidente de Paraguay Mario
abdo se ha hecho ver junto a Santiago
Peña y en general los actos como este de
fin de campaña han sido más pequeños Eso
sí el domingo sabremos que necesite
Paraguay si opta por la continuidad hoy
elige el cambio